you have established the character of
you Larry David as this guy who everyone
who knows the show knows that you speak
your mind you can say anything and it's
funny do you think you get away with
murder because of the show because the
excessive Curb Your Enthusiasm I think
that Larry David character on television
he start he's influencing my life a lot
and for the worst for that's you know
with terrible terrible results I am I've
become too much like him and I'm hurting
people you know you're hurt you want to
confess to a murder now but I'm hurting
people's feelings oh you are yes so the
old
so before Curb Your Enthusiasm came out
you were a guy who would think about
doing something but you wouldn't do it
but we do it now I do it what do you do
like he really give me an example okay
okay a guy last week is talking to me
about his dog yeah
excuse me something's coming up here
regret maybe yeah
[Applause]
blew my story so the guy says to me guys
he's got a dog you know he's talking
about his dog yeah and he says the dog
is so cute you know shows me a picture
yeah and I look at the picture yeah he
goes just alright yeah it looks like a
dog yeah
yeah and so the guy kind of walks away
and I go home and I'm thinking jeez what
the hell's wrong with you
it wasn't easy just ya know I know but
I've been influenced by the TV guy yeah
and the TV guy would have done would
have done that that would have been a
whole lap down
yeah so all night it bothered me and the
next day it bothered me and I had a look
I'm true story I sent him a text I'm so
sorry but the TV guy the TV guy that guy
you've got you've got the greatest out
now for anything you do yeah anything
you do in your life yeah you could take
scalding hot coffee and throw my face
burn me and then the next day like your
honor
it was my do it yeah now here's another
thing I don't want to ask you about
because when you're in front of the
camera and you work in this business
it's reality that people come up and
they want selfies I'm a people pleaser
yeah I like to make people happy and my
family always watches in astonishment as
I take selfies with everybody who wants
a selfie and it takes forever and
they're like we really got to go
are you that way no so are you
comfortable I mean cuz you're you're
also a nice guy you are you what you're
a nice guy but I could see you now I
mean it's I'm conflicted but I have a
good out now when I'm outside and they
asked me for a selfie right I go I don't
I don't do that outside that you know I
do that inside and then when I'm inside
I go I don't can't believe how well it
works yeah fantastic
yeah there's no rationale there is now
if I'm outside you know till there's a
lot of people around right right I do it
inside yeah I went on you can't do that
you know that guys the guys with the
cameras that want to talk to you when
you go to the airport or something
occasionally I've had luck with it like
Conan Conan can you tell us what you
think about it nothing like guys we're
gonna have to reschedule this and I've
had them go okay who schedules these
things but for a second they're like oh
he's right we should reschedule